les quatre dirigeants présents à kiev en
comptant le président roumain ont donc
annoncé soutenir l'octroi à l'ukraine du
statut officiel de pays candidat à
l'union européenne la commission doit
rendre son avis dans la journée on
retrouve pierre bénazet à bruxelles pour
france24 bonjour pierre alors c'est donc
une première étape que peut-on attendre
de la commission aujourd'hui après les
signaux positifs que l'on vient
d'entendre vous avez raison c'est une
première étape c'est en fait une
évaluation technique en quelque sorte
mais cette étape est relativement
indispensable pour toute demande
d'adhésion il faut évidemment que les
pays qui ont déposé leur candidature
puisse être jugé prêt pour rejoindre à
terme une procédure de négociation déjà
ça c'est à dire qu'il faut que les pays
soient proches ou en tout cas sur la
voie d'un rapprochement avec les
standards de l'union européenne en
l'occurrence on le sait et l'ours ou la
fin dallas l'a répété lorsqu'elle était
elle même à kiev au début de la semaine
avec volodymyr zelensky il y a des
problèmes qui se posent encore sur
l'état de droit en ukraine on sait que
le fonctionnement des institutions
ukrainienne pose problème en particulier
sur la lutte contre la corruption la
commission européenne est relativement
clair là dessus c'est une évaluation
technique donc ça veut dire aussi qu'à
une évaluation sur les conditions
économiques de l'ukraine surtout sur les
conditions juridiques le mode de
fonctionnement des institutions mais ça
là dessus on sait que la commission
européenne a décidé et ours la faute à
la hyène la répéter elle même qu'elle
voulait soutenir la candidature
ukrainienne soutenir les ukrainiens elle
le fera aussi probablement pour la
moldavie et c'est là aussi un symbole
politique en revanche pour la géorgie
qui elle aussi est candidate
officiellement demandé elle aussi de
pouvoir devenir candidate en revanche là
il ya peu de chances que la commission
européenne puisse donner son feu vert
c'était une opinion que la commission
européenne doit formellement adopté en
collège des commissaires aujourd'hui de
manière que jeudi et vendredi prochain
lors du sommet les chefs d'état de
gouvernement puisse prendre une décision
juridiquement ils ont besoin de ce feu
vert pour pouvoir avancer
alors pierre concrètement quelle est la
marge de manoeuvre de la commission
c'est que les 27 se réunissent la
semaine prochaine pour aborder cette
question oui effectivement ce sont eux
qui vont avoir la main très formellement
seule la ville sans l'avis de la
commission ils ne peuvent pas prendre de
décision la commission doit donc donner
son avis de manière motivé cette opinion
avec un certain nombre de critères qui
doivent être remplies on le sait la
commission européenne a toujours été
relativement technique parce que c'est
son travail en l'occurrence après ça le
fait d'ouvrir le statut de candidat
c'est juste une première étape on l'a vu
pour certains pays par exemple la
turquie a eu des années entre le moment
où elle a finalement eu le droit de
devenir candidate et le moment où des
négociations ont formellement ont été
ouvertes ça a duré quasiment vous ça a
duré plus de cinq ans et après ça les
négociations est le même c'est une autre
paire de manches parce que ça peut durer
en l'occurrence pour la turquie qui
s'est éloigné de l'union européenne
c'est des décennies et maintenance est
bloqué mais pour d'autres pays ça a duré
des années et des années c'est une étape
très technique il s'est surtout
l'opinion la position symbolique et
politique que la commission européenne
doit adopter aujourd'hui ça ouvre aussi
la voie évidemment à les fonds européens
supplémentaires est aussi un droit de
regard de l'union européenne sur la
façon dont l'ukraine évolué merci pour
toutes ces précisions pierre bénazet en
direct depuis bruxelles